when we talk about well how did it take
until 2021
for a show about the contributions of
black food to come out well because
black folks have not been the authors of
our own history in this country for
reasons that i think are obvious
right and so when you talk about food
what you're really talking about
uh and and why i think there's so much
intensity around it is twofold because
really you're talking about
um again a story of migration or
displacement a migration story
is either
your community your ancestors being
forced off of their land
right for for greater opportunity or
fleeing the land because they were under
threat in other words their way of life
could no longer happen in their homeland
and so this fracture
again oftentimes from marginalized
groups who have to leave
the homeland
the thing that we hold on to in our new
homes that we must piece together
are these cultural memories of the foods
of our home
that's what we get to take with us
yeah see this is fat i love this because
i think we don't think about food as a
shorthand for
identity ethnicity race culture even
religion right but it it so obviously is
the way that you talk about it and then
also you know you were talking about
this idea of like
you know we talk a lot about cultural
appropriation right it's a very big buzz
word right now but we don't talk enough
about food appropriation